good afternoon and welcome to a world
leaders
event co-sponsored with Columbia School
of International and public affairs our
guest today is Portuguese Prime Minister
josé sócrates carabeo
a fossa but he is usually known as by
his given names which was a Socrates he
will be delivering an address entitled
energy policy and the Portuguese growth
agenda
welcome mr. prime minister
Columbia University launched the world
leaders forum in 2003 as a
university-wide initiative to support
uninhibited dialogue on the most
pressing economic political
environmental and social questions of
our time questions that with each
passing year have larger and larger
global dimensions over the past seven
years the forum has offered an
opportunity for more than 15,000
students faculty and staff to directly
engage important figures from 48 nations
representing every corner of the world
our experience has confirmed the
animating principle of the world leaders
forum that only through informed
dialogue critical scholarship and a free
exchange of ideas will answer's emerge
to the biggest problems facing the world
today the role of universities in
creating a space for uninhibited and
critical discussion of controversial
issues has been noted on many occasions
if anything the changes we are seeing in
public discourse serves to heighten the
importance of this role universities are
not only places where difficult
conversations are respected and
encouraged today it sometimes appears
that universities may be the only
remaining venues where such
conversations occur with regularity we
are now nearly through a week of world
leaders forum events on our campus which
coincide with the fall meeting of the
United Nations General Assembly we have
heard from a broad and diverse group of
leaders from Africa Europe and Asia they
have challenged us with their views and
I think it is fair to say we have
challenged them thereby enriching our
understanding of the world tomorrow
we will hear addresses from the
presidents of Croatia and Turkey the
world leaders forum offers a offers a
unique opportunity to our students and
faculty to engage in conversations with
men and
directly involved in meeting the major
challenges of the 21st century an
opportunity that would be difficult if
not impossible to replicate in any other
city or at any other university we are
grateful to the heads of state and other
world leaders who continue to express a
strong interest in coming here to speak
Prime Minister Socrates was appointed
Portugal's Minister of Environment in
1999 he also has served as Minister for
youth and sport during which time he was
a chief organiser of the euro world cup
successfully hosted by Portugal in 2004
he became prime minister in 2005 and
last year was elected to a second term
the problems facing Portugal as a result
of the historic global financial and
economic crisis are familiar and in a
word daunting the twin challenges of
large national deficits and high rates
of unemployment are providing a stern
test for leaders throughout Europe and
much of the world and Portugal is no
exception
in this difficult time the Prime
Minister has continued to pursue
Portugal's ambitious program of
developing alternative sources of energy
taking advantage of the nation's
abundant access to Sun sea and wind the
Prime Minister's sustainable energy
programme invested over has invested
over 18 billion dollars in listing both
public and private resources to meet its
targets the program's focus on
technology and innovation includes
substantial support for vocational
training and education the Portuguese
government forecasts that by the close
of this year 45 percent 45 percent of
the nation's electricity consumption
will be supplied by renewable sources
with the goal of producing 60% of its
electricity from clean sources by the
end of the decade should Portugal
succeed in meeting this goal the
nation's reliance on alternative energy
we'll be three times the target
established by the European Commission
for its member countries and various
orders of magnitude higher than anything
dreamed of in this country I might add
clearly
energy policy is a topic of central
significance at this university and
Prime Minister Socrates is clearly one
of the best qualified world leaders to
discussion
Portugal's achievements I should also
mention are well known at the School of
International and public affairs at
Columbia where Manuel Pino who was the
Minister of Economy and innovation and
who helped at the time these reforms
were introduced and who helped implement
Portugal's new energy strategy is now
serving as a very distinguished visiting
professor of this semester mr. Prime
Minister we are all extremely interested
in hearing from you today please join me
in welcoming Prime Minister Portuguese
Prime Minister Jose
mr. Dean I want very much to express my
thanks to your kind invitation to be
with you this afternoon and I want to
tell you and all the professors and
students here that it's a honor for me
to be at Columbia University and to have
the opportunity to address such a
distinguished stinkweed audience of
students and professors of these
University I will follow the advice of
my good friend mr. Manuel Pina that is
present here he advised me to express
myself not in English but in the
international language we used to
communicate
bad English so please watch out I will
speak in English and if you allow me I
will go directly to the subject energy
and the most important I have to tell
you is DS is to describe to you the
experience of my country on energy and
to describe to you one of the most
important and structural reforms of our
economy and of our society and the point
I want very much to underline in the
short communication is this it's
possible to make structural reforms
important reforms in several fields but
also on energy in a very short period of
time it's possible to do it
see the situation in Portugal in 2005
Portugal was one of the country's debt
depends more on fossil energy Portugal
was one of the countries that depends
more of the importation of oil Portugal
was one of the countries that is a huge
problem in our trade balance explained
by the deficit of our energy we import
so much from abroad that it caused 50%
of our deficit read balance and more
Portugal was one of the countries that
explored the less of our local resources
on energy for instance Portugal was the
European country that let's exploit the
edrick power potential potential of our
country this is the this was the
situation in 2005 in 2009 in four years
Portugal is nowadays the fifth country
in the ranking of renewables in Europe
and in the world the fifth Portugal is
the 18th in the world ranking on
environmental performance as the Dean
says forty five percent of our
electricity in 2009 was produced based
on local renewables and
45% in the first Simenson semester
semester yes of this year the first
semester 66% of our electricity was
based on renewable energy and for the
first time we export more electricity
that we import we add not a death that
is traditional in our country but a
super habit on the trade of electricity
for the first time and with that
conditions we avoid the import of 100
million errors of fossil fuels this is
the situation nowadays we have in
Portugal the largest park
aeolic park sorry in operation in Europe
and we have the second highest level of
incorporation of wind power in Europe
the second the first is Denmark
the situation is change very soon and in
a large proportion in our dimension and
if you if we saw the rankings the
economic rankings on innovation on
environmental we saw the positions of
Portugal ed grow very quickly and as you
probably don't know Portugal is nowadays
one of the leader countries in terms of
to create the conditions to have the
electric car in our society 2005 2009
but those achievements of our country
allow us to create now better and more
ambitious targets for the future
objectives to 2020
first of all in 2020 we want to have 60%
of our electricity produced from local
renewable sources 60% we want to have
more 20% increase in energy efficiency
and we want to reduce 20% in co2
emissions this is in line with European
strategy yes but we are in the
leadership of Europe in terms of new
targets new investments and new projects
on energy for instance we are investing
3.7 billion euros doubling the installed
capacity on wind energy nowadays I
believe we have 4,000 megawatts of wind
energy and we intend to reach 8,000 in
2020 we have in Portugal the most
important and most ambitious project to
a more contribution of Adric power to
our production of electricity until 2020
we will move from 344 megawatts to 574
megawatts we have projects in all the
renewables not only on wind energy
not only in hydric energy but also in
solar energy and also in wave energy and
we are supporting all the investments in
those areas in those areas every year
some companies appear we are increasing
jobs and activity economic activity and
only to give you some figures it's very
important you to know that nowadays we
have a very efficient and modern cluster
of renewables in our country more than
20,000 people in Portugal as a job in a
company that is working on renewable
company renewable energy it shows very
clear that power bet on renewables is
not only a question of Independence of a
country is not only a question to reduce
co2 emissions is not a question to be on
the right side against the climate
change it's also about economy and to
create jobs and this is real the mix
that we operate to create a huge
transformation in our economy and in our
society and I I want to be very clear to
you I consider the field of energy the
transformation we made on energy the
most important and structural
transformation in our economy it's not
only the image of our country is not
only
to have good positions in several
environmental rankings it's also the
presence we have in one at the fields
debt in the modern economy will receive
the better in an innovation and the
better in research and development of
course unfortunately there are not a
technical proposition a proposal
scientific proposal to assure the rows
of growing for the countries we know
that unfortunately they are not received
received you understand that I meant a
proposal a scientific proposal that the
politicians can follow in order to
achieve growth but I'm very well
convinced that on energy is one of the
fields one of the driving forces of the
new economy of this century so what can
I tell you about the secrets and success
what can I tell you what were the
conditions to succeed in the
transformation in the shesh in this view
I will tell you three things about that
first it's necessary to have a strategy
when I study on my MBA I had a
discipline called enterprise strategy or
something like that
and I remember the first phrase the
first statement of the Manoir it goes
like this strategy is about winning it
sounds me always like a verse strategy
is about women and I cannot share ok I
can assure all of you there are there
will be no success without strategy and
the secret for this transformation we
made in our country in only four years
was first of all to have a clear
strategy and a clear strategy that we
can explain to everyone in our society
because this strategy to bet on
renewables is something that we can
explain to my country very clearly first
of all is very very important to reduce
our dependence of oil
the second is best way to contribute to
a better environment third is very
important there Portugal joint the
nations that are making efforts to
create a better economy a greener
economy a low-carbon economy and finally
these transformations create jobs new
approach opportunities for business
those were the reasons that create a
very good social environment to support
our national strategy so first of all we
succeed because we add strategy but
second is not only a question of
strategy it's a question of enforcement
strategy is not only the conception of
strategy
one part is the conception but the other
part and I can tell you the hard part of
these is to put strategy on the ground
is to is to it's not only the conception
of the whole thing is the execution and
if I can tell you something about these
for the future in my country we will
need 5% of conception be attention to
the changes that are going on in this
field around the world but all we need
more is to exercise to put things on the
ground to make it happen not only to
create to conceive that make it and
believe me this is not easy
probably is the most difficult part that
story and finally the third point of the
success is not a plan for the state is
not a plan for public policies no it
should be a plan to involve all the
society and all the businessmen and good
companies and to mobilize them to create
a movement in Spanish it can be said
there to create a Movida I know the
Spiritist second language in the United
States and I know all of you understand
this concept concept of Movida
dynamism movement in order to achieve
the goals we want to achieve so this is
really a huge transformation but let me
finish my present initially
and I will be very glad to answer your
questions and to make some dialogue with
you to underline one of our most
important projects in Portugal is not
only the wind energy is not only
Diedrich energy is not the investment we
are making on solar is not only the wave
energy we are developing we are the
first country in the world developing
the first technology to advise the
production of energy on waves but is
this project I think will be reality
very soon the electric car the electric
mobile not only cars but to buyers
bicycles G electric car I think it will
be one of the most important and most
promising changes in the area of energy
in Portugal we are one that the
countries in the world that are creating
now the first National Grid - what's the
name in English to recharge the
batteries on cars soon only said the
most important car constructors it's not
American but I think they have some
business also in America decided to
build the first the first fabric of the
first plant on batteries in Portugal and
he decided that because they recognize
the efforts of the government and the
business companies that are with great
attention on this business business to
develop the new car of the future
the electric car well I understand we
look at me
we had some suspicious it will be a
success or not let me tell you one story
I remember one day I was Member of
Parliament in the 80s I was very young
but I was spokeman
of my party for the questions of
Environment and I remember the first
time we received a delegation from
Denmark and they made the presentation
of the most important bet then the
country made on wind energy you cannot
imagine the sinnism and the laughs I saw
in the face and smiles in the face of so
many people that don't believe that that
kind of energy the wind energy could be
competitive because the prices because
these are debt nowadays after 10 years
of efforts Denmark is the leading
country on wind energy and they are
selling everywhere their technology and
they are selling now for the United
States and they have the first company
in the world on wind energy technology
we are on their track fortunately we
have not first but the third most
largest company on renewables in the
world but believe me the electric car
we'll change the atmosphere and the
landscape of our cities for a moment
imagine the following imagine a city
with cars that s two features features
first no emissions second no noise no
noise no emissions do you think the
citizens if we will have 10% of the cars
in one city without emissions and
without noise they will want to be back
I don't believe I think the electric car
is one the most important
transformations that the beginning of
the new center will bring to us and to
our society so the field of energy is I
feel a very full of promises for the
future one at the living fields of
transformation of our economy and not
only economy but also in the environment
and it's also a fuel business full of
opportunities and I think that's why I
have so many young people here believe
me this field will give you great
opportunities for your future thank you
very much
so Prime Minister's office has
graciously agreed to answer some
questions if you would like to ask them
please move towards the microphones and
form a line there before you ask I will
be calling on you before you ask your
question I would ask you to please state
your name and your school of Columbia so
we can get started with you hi I'm Kevin
Pullman I go to the school of general
studies one thing it's very important is
first of all there are some differences
between Portugal and the United States
first of all the size second of all to
different landscapes up the United
States is much broader but my question
really is just keep that in mind as last
my question my question is the United
States states have spent hundreds of
billions of dollars on bailouts and
economic stimulus plans do you think
they should have used some of that money
for this things you're talking about
it's but more specifically how do you
think they should have specifically use
that money how if they should have used
some of that money for renewable energy
how could they have either not just in
research and and so forth but a little
more specifically first of all all the
countries that all the states the public
administrations that wants to give an
impulse to their economies don't find a
better field to invest than energy there
are so much things to do on energy so
new developments on energy debt if you
want to create jobs give opportunities
of business and create a better
environment you will find on energy a
very very good field to invest so all
the countries are doing their best in
order to put public money and private
money to follow the new tendons on
energy it will be a huge competition but
I noticed that your president
in the first speeches he made we make it
clear that the field of energy will be
one of the fields that the American
administration will invest more in order
to develop the sector in order to create
new opportunities new jobs but also in
order to follow the new path of United
States to to reduce the co2 emissions I
think the new administration of your
country is compromised with the new
objectives the negotiations we made
after the Kyoto Protocol and but to be
honest with you
the needs creates the opportunity to
make new strategies portugal as more
needs that unite them
united states in the air health energy
because we depend more from oil than the
united states we don't produce all
neither gas and we have a huge trade
deficit right balance created by the
energy that's why we felt the need to
create a new strategy to and to exploit
the hours reason our local resources and
that's why the new strategy on energy
comes out thank you
bitch and I'm happy that you are making
such developments in a very important
field my question involves something
that is indirectly related to your
country's effort and the field of energy
after hearing President Obama and
Ahmadinejad speak at the UN I wanted to
see your ideas on the United States and
Iran relations and what is the foreign
policy that protocol has in respect to
Iran I think we have the same policy
Portugal the United States the respect
of international law
and I think this is the challenge for
all the governments and for all the
administration's to make the
international policy based on
international rules and laws this is
most important and the most ending in
these times in New York with the General
Assembly of the United Nations going on
is the moment to underline this
principle the respect of international
law and please remind you to state your
name in school Nnamani Colombia Brazil
to questions they are related to each
other the first question is did you face
any reactions from oil companies
traditional fossil fuel companies in
Portugal while you were implementing
those changes and the second question is
was the oil or the energy problem the
biggest impediment for the improvement
of the economy in Portugal or there were
bigger challenges and if there were
bigger challenges what they were what
all those challenges thank you listen if
you ask me what are the fields the most
important fields of investment and
transformation in the Portuguese economy
I will tell you that in
three or four words energy new
technology on information and
communication technology we are making a
new great effort on that by the way I
don't know if all of you are familiar
with that but Portugal is the leading
country country in the ranking of Igor
meant in Europe I would I will tell you
it again Portugal is the leading country
on the ranking of the e-government is
something four years ago we were at the
18th place now we are the leading
country so we have a challenge on techno
telecommunications and information and
communications technology and the area
of science and education if you ask me
tell me the three most important areas
of the development that Portugal should
face energy development the information
and communication technologies and
either education science these were two
three areas your first question I'm
sorry I could I was asking you fix any
reactions
ah the reactions and it's very
interesting no the first no I didn't
because for a very understandable reason
we don't have oil in Portugal so we have
Cantonese but owned on the fields of
refining oil and not to exploit oil but
some of them were have some doubts on
these but I think now they are involved
in these
huge transformations the oil companies
in Portugal major one is involved on the
projects of our military cars is
involved on wind energy and they took
the opportunity to diversify their
business the case is very different in a
country that has oil like United States
but in general I can tell you that the
reaction of the business community was
very good in the direction to to opportu
take opportunities in the evening mr.
prime minister my question to you is
that besides the tremendous change in
the energy policy of Portugal and the
governance what do you consider to be
the single biggest achievement of your
tenure as a prime minister of Portugal
I'm sorry I didn't - what is the what
what do you consider to be your single
biggest achievement as the prime
minister of Portugal besides the policy
I'm a modest man so I will not take half
an hour to describe all my achievements
but I can tell you jeez one of the huge
I'm a socialist well here in the United
States you I think you call liberal to
the Social Democrats in Europe but we
made a very tough and very ambitious
transformation in our social security we
made for reforms in only two years in
2005 in 2006
first of all all public servants in
Portugal goes to
retirement with 60 years old not anymore
now they go to retirement as the same
age of the private employees 65 this is
the first change the second we achieve
transformation in order to consider all
the contribution career of the people
and not the best 10 years of the last 15
that is the European quasi conditions to
the Talco of the pension and the third
we make a new introduction in Social
Security on the calculus pensions we
affect the calcio with the
sustainability factor that compares the
life expectancy in 1 january of 2006
with life expectancy in the moment you
retired so for the first time we
introduced more fairness in the
calculate the pension because the state
only have the money to pay some years if
the years girls longer with more life
expectancy the the state only have two
possibilities to give to the citizen or
you work more or you win less in the old
years so it was one of the huge and most
profound reforms in Europe that has been
done during the beginning of this
century but I want to tell you this with
this reform we create conditions to have
such a public Social Security and we
want that Social Security public
we don't need private it's a European
perspective thank you thank you for your
question
good evening mr. prime minister my name
is max Druze I'm a freshman at Columbia
College a question has to do with
Portugal's drug policy in 2001 Portugal
became the first European country to
abolish all criminal penalties for
personal drug position what is your
stance on this issue and what do
countries like America Mexico and Brazil
need to learn about drug policy it is
not easily like that
because you know I was in charge in the
moment we made this transformation I was
the minister in charge when I was
Minister of of sports and youth I had
the responsibility on drugs policy and I
made that refund and direct debt reform
was the following
we accept two modifications first of all
we insist in the line to protect risks I
don't know the expression in English to
tell this but the idea is to use all the
instruments is to accept that drug
physics exists and to use all the
instruments to reduce the harm to the
society and all the new programs
methadone
what's the English expression for 3
gauge needles distribution of needles
all those projects result of their
strategy but in terms of conception we
decided the following is not exactly as
as I said Matt III explained to all of
you we decided in intelligent movement
because my country like yours is part of
the United Nations in the United Nations
s resolutions Paulo common policies on
that and we cannot put as a part of the
international conventions on drugs but
we decided not to consider the
conception of drugs like a crime we
decided to do is is far bitten but it's
not a crime is some
something like you pay a fine like the
traffic the traffic violations of the
rules I don't I don't know the exactly
expression in English to separate the
penile situations from in my country we
used to call it the Contra control of
national policy it's something that you
can you don't go to prison but you pay a
fine it's better to deal the to do with
the consumers drugs and the most
important to tell you is this the
transformations we made in terms of drug
policy is was this we change from a
ideological ideological policy for a
pragmatic policy to support us in
results to better results and it works
we are very happy with that thank you
for you one more question for chants in
English so they wouldn't be able to
understand so I prefer to do it in
English okay my name is Marco Machado
I'm a student at Columbia College and
communal that means you had mentioned
before in your speech that a strategy is
necessary to combat the energy crisis
that we're facing and that strategy
needs to be compiled together not only
with politicians but with scientists and
professionals like many of the students
here that have gone to universities that
and that know how to create systems
where you can form renewable energies at
the same time last week when you were in
the University of Madeira you made
something of a pledge that by the year
2020 you wanted 40% of the population
that's between the ages of 30 and 34
years old to have you
thirty degrees even though that number
at present is well below that forty
percent my question primarily is how
exactly do you wish to attain that forty
percentage
seeing as how many of the professionals
and many of the other people in Portugal
that obtain university degrees end up
leaving the country whether for better
working conditions or better salaries do
you plan on forming some sort of
incentive we're okay if you go for some
sort of degree that helps you inform you
know companies with renewable energy
sources or create some sort of strategic
plan in working with the government you
get some sort of incentive so maybe it's
cheaper or something like that I'd like
to know what your idea is now I have no
intention on that because I don't think
it's necessary and I want to give you
some figures some articles first of all
you are completely right
the objective of Portugal is in 2022 a
forty percent the people with twenty
years old studying in the university
this is our objective but nowadays now
sorry it's not like that we want to have
40 percent from the people the people
from 25 to 34 with academic university
degree but nowadays in this present
moment 35 36 percent of the Portuguese
with 20 years old studying in the
university and I can assure you this
when I was at university only 3% of the
people with 20 years were at university
and it was one of the most impressive
modifications in our country the Eiger
education our University and
I don't know if you are aware with this
but let me if you allow me make some
propaganda of my government we have in
our universities since last year's a
convenience contracts protocols with
American universities not unfortunately
with Columbia University but with the
MIT Austin University and carrying a
Mellon University and with also with the
Harvard University we have nowadays very
opened universities and I want to share
with you this little story two months
ago the Dean of our largest University
the University of Porto was elected and
you know something they were they add
two candidates one Portuguese and the
other was an American for the first time
the Portuguese universities allow any
professor in the world from China
knighted States Vietnam you name it if
he has the conditions to do it
to be a Dean University in Portugal
this was one the reforms I'm proud of
but the achievement is very easy not
only to continue the
the the work that we have been done
during these years in terms to insist on
education and higher education but let
me tell you the following figure we have
the idea in Portugal only in Portugal
that the brilliant brains of our country
go abroad it's not true some girls and
we are proud of them we are proud of the
Portuguese that comes to America make
their professional and academic lives
here or in the other countries of Europe
and they are doing their job to give
prestige to our country but in this
present moment I want you to know that
we have 7.2 scientists for 8,000
Portuguese working and this is a figure
that is either that European average 7.2
scientists for each thousand Portuguese
working so we have Portuguese abroad yes
we have and we are proud of them but we
have so many people from outside for an
America from Germany from Spain
everywhere comes to Portugal and believe
me Portugal is a very good country to
make silence
I guess nobody got into five
good afternoon mr. prime minister I am
also Portuguese it's your name in school
my advisor I'm an MBA student here at
Columbia my question relates a bit to
what you were talking to what you're
saying just now is what do you think are
Portugal main arguments or as that study
here all the people that you get people
to study abroad in abroad to go back to
Portugal and resume their professional
lives
I think Portugal unlike the other
European countries it's a country of
opportunities one thing that you
probably know Portugal is one of the
countries where to be to be educated
Peyman the difference between the salary
of education educating people and not
now educated people the difference is
bigger in our country that's why I
insist so much that one of our most
important challenge is the
qualifications of our people and I'm
very proud you are here in Colombia you
know I spend all my life thinking when
my opportunity to live and study abroad
terms fortune didn't come I had not the
opportunity but I happened to be prime
minister who knows it's so it's so it's
so interesting to come to this
university to see a campus university
campus in in America when I came my head
of cabinet told me well it's so
beautiful is that it creates the
impression that our most important wheel
is to stay here for the last two years
studying and thinking and not not action
but reflection all the politicians are
made of action but sometimes I need also
to reflect and to study enjoy the
opportunity to
the American University and all the best
to you thank you thank you mr. prime
minister and you should know that we
would always be happy to welcome you as
you see there's a lot of interest on the
country we I know that you're running to
an event do you want to have a last last
we give you the last word over three
minutes well this you want to take
another question yes take a last
question thank you very much mr. prime
minister my name is Tim Weber and I am a
first year at the school of science I
really appreciate your and your
country's commitment to renewable
resources now my question is regarding
the infrastructure of those electrical
resources with the intermittent nature
of such resources resources such as wind
power and solar power what sort of
changes did your country need to make in
order to handle those new powers in
their infrastructure and do you think
such changes could be applied here in
the United States where electrical
infrastructure is owned by so many
different companies I have no doubt that
the United States as a challenge like
all the other industrialized countries
to make the modifications our economy
needs in terms to be competitive
compatible with the objectives on
environment and we have so much to do
but when we are living in the times like
these in times of crisis I think we
should look at the world that should be
done in order to compensate the impacts
on environment of our economy that we
should look at that problems as
opportunities to do something to create
new jobs and new
and believe me in my experience when we
can explain a clear strategy when we can
explain to our citizens and to our
businessmen a clear strategy and after
four years with results is very easy to
convince society to follow the path of
transformation in the beginning
I didn't said that student that make the
question of course in all societies are
some people that defends out other other
possibilities we have in my country some
people that defend the investment on
nuclear plants I never D defended that
for several reasons but there are
pragmatic reasons also if one country
decided in Europe to create nuclear plan
the time that is necessary from the
moment you decided from the moment that
nuclear plant is on operation is almost
30 years we cannot wait 20 years we
should have a strategy for those 20
years and not for the second part of the
century that's why I think that we have
the why I had very clear in our in front
of us is the bet on renewables we knew
force is the answer to shops to economy
to energy and also to the environment
and if you allowed me professor I want
to once again to thank you all for the
kindness
this reception once again I'm very proud
and honored to be in such a
distinguished University and I want you
to know that for me it was a very good
opportunity to present experience of my
country I had fewer experiences to
address American students but I should
tell you this monopoly knows that I
considered September at the best part of
the life of a prime minister European
prime minister because this moment you
should go to the United States to make a
speech and spend two days in New York in
September thank you very much
you